just over a year ago i created a very
unconventional wedding for gabby and i
in our backyard with
guests made out of cardboard boxes a
priest over zoom
and a fake wedding band all because of
the global lockdown
as great and spontaneous as this was i
really wanted to give gabby the wedding
she deserved so a year later when
restrictions dropped a bit we were
finally able to do so
we did the whole traditional shebang
with all the bells and whistles
i really wanted to keep the ceremony in
most parts of this wedding private for
our family and loved ones
that's why i didn't make a video about
it i did however take a video camera
with on our honeymoon
brand new
[Music]
[Music]
to be alive feeling free a work of art
find your heart find your heart behind
your heart high key love is on my trip
boomboyage and leave a tip
did you know that we are 10 minutes
drive
away from arguably the sharkiest bay
well i'm very glad i didn't see any
wetsuits packed
i did something bad i booked us to go
shark age diving
i think it would be good for like our
fear of sharks
it might help your fear of sharks i
think i might stay afraid
i even bought this i was going to do
something cool with it
tomorrow morning first thing before we
head into questionably the worst
decision i've ever made
i would like to introduce the sponsor of
this video storybox which is the
complete stock solution for creators and
businesses alike
providing an unlimited library of high
quality royalty-free audio and images
through cost-effective subscription
plans
storyblocks is just such a great way to
speed up your creative process this site
really does have the highest quality
stocks
footage textures illustrations
everything you need to do what you do
best or essentially
tell a story in the most visual way with
the unlimited library over 1 million as
strong all yours to download and use
anywhere you bound to find what you need
with the unlimited
all access subscription plan
i've been asked by a significant amount
of irish
brews i think irish british wales
to try this drink iron brew so i ordered
one
[Music]
oh brewed in scotland scottish it's good
back to the sharks define your fear for
sharks
i know my fear is not for like sharks
specifically i'm just terrified of the
ocean i think in general
everything's inside of it yeah one time
i took cab surfing the one time
and afterwards i asked her how was that
and she said yeah i think i like surfing
i just don't like the waves
but for me i have a phobia of sharks and
i've been working with discovery plus on
this new show called immersions
and the first episode is coming out soon
which is called song of the shark it's
all about
sharks so i feel that i have to immerse
myself with with sharks
it's only fair i've made a film about
sharks
and i don't actually like sharks you
like them you're just scared of them
yeah i appreciate them from afar yeah
okay
so i'm now going to appreciate them from
a close
okay okay
it's important to note that this is an
eco-friendly shark diving experience
this means that the sharks are not fed
with chan and they are all looked after
by the daya island conservation trust
program where the money earned from
tourism is put back into the upkeep of
our oceans
they purposely make us look like seals
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i want to get on now get out of here
you know what [ __ ] what is paying to
come on an experience to make your fear
worse let's get off this boat
yeah time to get off the boat we're
gonna go to the mountains where it's
safe
to the mountains
[Applause]
[Music]
introduce the plant it's a protea what
is it
it's a protea but what is its
significance
it's our national flower there you have
it our national flower
grab it go
one down
that usually works
oh my
[Music]
i wanted to show you this really rad
technique where gabs are now going to be
making s'mores at the bottom of frame
here in slow motion while the stars are
going to rotate
above us let's see if it works
[Music]
good morning from the town of bart
skirter
or scared the divorce bar
scared the balls [ __ ] i just wanted to
say thank you to the sponsor of this
week's videos story blocks but i also
don't wake up
gabs so i'm going to cut to this brown
reed in my studio recently storyblocks
hired
six lgbtqia plus directors
creators and filmmakers to build new
footage collections for their library so
that these communities can be
authentically represented in stock
footage
something that they traditionally have
not been they're also doing this for
other underrepresented communities like
black indigenous and people of color you
can learn more about this initiative
called
restart as well as go subscribe to
storyblocks and get in on
unlimited driven footage if you click
the link in my description
clicking that link helps support my
channel as well as helps you become a
better filmmaker
so yeah thank you storyblocks other than
that don't forget you're awesome
and i'll see you next week